what's going on guys this is rob and
with thor 4 coming out and us basically
getting russell crowe zeus the number
one question people are going to be
asking
[Laughter]
is who is more powerful
odin or zeus so all we really have to
draw on here is really marvel comics
honestly this is the first time we're
seeing russell crowe zeus we have no
idea what he's capable of and i would
really agree with most opinions out
there in saying that the reason we're
even getting zeus in this movie is to
illustrate how powerful gore is that
gore is powerful enough to kill beings
like zeus that we and the average person
would look at as seeing somebody
comparable to odin and saying damn he's
that powerful right he basically
by killing zeus he could have in effect
killed odin most likely possibly we
won't really know because odin's been
dead since thor ragnarok so uh one of
the cool things here and really what we
have to draw on again is looking at
comics now the number one place that
most people look at is like a marvel
cosmic hierarchy the biggest issue that
you have when it comes to cosmic
hierarchies though is that more often
than not they focus largely on cosmic
beings right abstract so like the cosmic
entities master order lord chaos
eternity infinity living tribunal all
that kind of stuff and by and large that
hierarchy is pretty straightforward that
you've usually got the living tribunal
at the top you've got eternity and
infinity under him you have like caveat
characters so like the beyonder the
molecule man the phoenix force sometimes
when it's like jean grey with the white
phoenix of the crown protege marquee of
death right different things like that
but sticking largely with like the the
continuous beings that are always there
and are always powerful under eternity
and infinity you usually got like master
order lord chaos sire hate mistress love
different things like that and then
depending on the circumstances like the
stranger maybe or the celestials
galactus whatever um but in the thanos
wins story arc you actually end up
getting like odin and zeus who were
thrown in there now one of the big
things that are up for debate about this
is that in this particular cosmic
hierarchy depiction we are given the
living tribunal at the top we're given
eternity and infinity none of the caveat
characters are given to us here under
eternity and infinity you're given
master order lord chaos mistress love
and sire hate and then on the fourth
level which people kind of debate this
you're given galactus the celestials it
looks like chronos although it might be
the in-betweener and then you're given
uh odin zeus and the stranger now
conventional wisdom based on just
general knowledge of marvel comics if
you've read long enough is that galactus
and the celestials are above odin and
zeus and a lot of that really goes back
to like the arrival of the third host
the idea that like the sky fathers so
odin zeus and the various other you know
earthly pantheon of gods band together
they tried to fight off the celestials
they used to destroy your armor and then
celestials annihilate to destroy your
armor and they're just like if you keep
this up we will kill all of you and
ultimately the the sky fathers basically
back off things like that you can kind
of use the transitive property to a
degree and say well galactus is
comparable to the celestials so
obviously galactus is more powerful than
odin or zeus there is however a story in
is it i think it's rick remender's run
on thor i'm not going to swear to that
i'm not going to swear there's rick
reminders run
but there is a point where odin fights
galactus and just headbutts the hell out
of him and like that one attack is
enough to put odin into the odin's sleep
and it just kind of leaves galactus a
little dizzy right so little things like
that where maybe they're comparable but
in this particular instance you
basically get odin and zeus who are put
on an even keel and it's just like these
two guys are even in terms of their
power and there have been things like
that like i'm pretty sure during greg
pack's incredible hulk's run you did get
a fight between odin and zeus and they
were argued to be equal but the bigger
problem with this though is that once
you wind the clock back and you go
further back in marvel comics what you
end up running into is a situation where
you actually find that marvel's kind of
established in different ways over the
years that odin is more powerful than
zeus a really good example of this and
one that a lot of people point to is a
combination of things right so like thor
annual number five from 1966 um if you
look at thor
618 from 2007 um it's one of these
things where you're basically given an
indication of how old odin is and that
odin is billions of years old right that
he existed before time itself uh how
exactly that happens i don't entirely
know because given the events of thor
ragnarok or thor disassembled that odin
had previously had essentially come into
existence with the rest of the universe
he'd been reborn which was basically the
cycle of ragnarok ending with the death
of the universe or the the multiverse or
what have you right whatever area you
want to follow but the thing about that
is that odin is incredibly old a lot of
people use that as a way to argue that
just based on longevity right his
experience in like fighting battles and
things like that that he is more
experienced than zeus is however a lot
of people look to zeus in terms of just
being stronger and more capable than
odin however odin is wiser than zeus and
so while zeus is the better fighter odin
knows when to avoid a fight and when to
engage in a fight but having said all of
that uh most fans consider
odin to just be stronger than zeus and
for one particular caveat that reason
basically being odin being in possession
of the odin force that that's the one
thing that gives him a kind of trump
card that without the odin force without
the life force of basically his brothers
veli and v
that odin would just be comparable if
not just flat out equal to uh to zeus in
terms of power but the odin force is
what just generally gives him the extra
edge between the two um having said that
in terms of how they compare in the
marvel cinematic universe it's hard to
tell right i mean it's going to be a
difficult thing to tell and it's really
for a variety of reasons the first is
because we're just now being introduced
to zeus and we don't know how much of
his character we're going to get in the
marvel cinematic universe it could be
one of those things where like when
we're introduced to zeus by way of
valkyrie or or maybe even like hercules
himself or like jane foster whatever the
case is or perhaps zeus just runs over
his own history in there we end up
getting these little things where they
talk about the various battles that like
zeus and odin had fought and how odin
had always lost to zeus or something
along those lines now if we get that
you'll probably end up seeing people who
just want to continue believing that
odin is stronger than zeus kind of
coming up with things like well zeus was
just saying that to make himself look
more impressive than he was whatever the
case is i don't know right like when it
comes to comic books people believe what
they want to believe right so the the
thing about this is that we won't really
know for sure the other big reason why
it's going to be difficult to tell
between the two is because by and large
we've never actually seen odin fight not
in a real true knock down drag drag-out
fight we never really saw that by the
time odin came onto the scene he was
basically retired right he's like i mean
anything that really requires my
attention in terms of a conflict is
basically done so i just chill right you
know he just hangs out in asgard never
really does anything and just chastises
thor from time to time and like that's
basically it we did see a couple of
instances like i think it was born in uh
thor 2 in thor the dark world who was
fighting off against like malikith and
those guys right using a bit of a
transitive property there you could say
like if he was that capable of a fighter
he would have taught his son very much
the same way so odin was at least as
powerful as more if not more powerful
there's different ways to interpret that
but in terms of just a straight up knock
down drag out fight we never really got
to see that so we don't really know
exactly what it is that odin is capable
of we just know he's really powerful um
if i was a betting man to be honest with
you guys if i were a straight betting
man and i had to offer an opinion that
people are anxiously waiting for if for
no other reason than to just disagree
with it i would say
that it's most likely odin is more
powerful than zeus that that you know
anthony hopkins odin could overpower
russell crowe's zeus the funny thing
about this though and this is one of the
things to keep in mind when you're
talking about guys like that
there does come a point when it comes to
the sky fathers that they don't really
fight per se that they meet and
occasionally they do stuff but in terms
of like sheer just knock down drag out
fights unless you're talking about
something like the chaos king or
somebody who's like intentionally
invading like olympus or asgard or
something like that you're not really
going to see a lot of instances where
they engage in combat those days are for
the most part long since gone for them
there was an amazing moment when zeus
took the incredible hulk to the woodshed
that was amazing he beat the hell out of
him
just to watch zeus beat the crap out of
the hulk was just absolutely amazing now
had that fight gone on long enough the
hulk would have just easily overpowered
zeus right world breaker hulk would
probably be able to crush zeus maybe i
don't know i'm just ballpark ballparking
there right heart of the monster hulk
absolutely would be able to titan hulk
would do it without even just without
breaking a sweat but in terms of just
the incredible hulk yeah he got smacked
around more than a few times by uh by
zeus it was pretty cool to see but uh
but outside of that again you know i
would say that the the winner of this
bout most likely goes to odin right goes
to anthony hopkins odin um but again i'm
interested to see what they do because i
feel like this is a question the mcu
knows exists out there there there's a
question people are going to want an
answer to when they get into the movie i
don't think people are going to want to
see a fight i mean it'd be cool to see
but i don't think like the main focus of
anybody going into thor 4 is like man i
really hope we get a scene where like
zeus fights odin even if it's just a
flashback i think most people are
focused on like watching gore just kill
all the gods across these different
parts of the universe uh and most likely
kill zeus but um but i think that it'd
be a cool reference and it's something
that people would i don't know maybe
kind of expect to see or talked about in
some form or fashion some establishment
as to who's more powerful um zeus or
odin i imagine if the mcu does handle
that they'll probably play both sides of
the fence right it'll probably be one of
those things where like somebody asked
the question right you know where like
star-lord or someone's like so who's
more powerful like you or odin and
thor's like well of course it's my
father and zeus just kind of looks at
him funny for a second and he's like
you know that we won't worry about that
right it just kind of it under the rug
right it just never really gives an
answer i could see that being the case
and honestly i think it'd be funny more
of like a comedic element to that people
who are like die hard and want a
definitive answer will probably get mad
about it but they'll be okay but having
said that you know again just kind of my
take on this i would give it to odin i
would say odin's probably more powerful
than zeus if we're talking about both
guys in their prime fighting against
each other but marvel comics gives us
different depictions sometimes odin's
more powerful than zeus sometimes
they're equal i don't really think
there's been an instance in marvel
comics when they've established that
zeus is actually more powerful than odin
uh so i guess you can just kind of go
with that but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace